the legend of zelda is a franchise
widely known respected
and loved for being the perfect
combination of the three cornerstones of
what makes a good game in my opinion
a compelling narrative an emotional
soundtrack and superb gameplay that
always introduces something new
zelda games have largely followed this
formula since the days of a link to the
past but the newest game
breath of the wild set out to change
that formula by focusing on gameplay
more than anything
creating the most monumentally
successful zelda game ever in terms of
sales however
as i mentioned earlier it is my and many
others opinions that there are other
elements that make a zelda game feel
more like a zelda game
namely a strong narrative while breath
of the wild story which was really more
of a backstory
was incredibly strong the way it was
told was through disconnected
non-linear optional cutscenes that took
away from the story's
impact for some when the announcement
trailer for age of calamity was revealed
to us one of the first things i said was
that if it expounded upon breath of the
wild's hazy backstory
it may just create the truly greatest
zelda game ever since you would have to
credit
its story to the original game but now
that i and more fans by the day are
discovering the story of age of calamity
the statement that i had made has
somewhat changed
in some ways for the better and others
for the worse consider this a spoiler
warning by the way for those who haven't
finished the story or watched the
cutscenes online yet you see age of
calamity tells a different story than
what we know the backstory is in breath
of the wild
there are reasons for this which i
predicted in an older video of mine but
because of this it's impossible to not
compare and contrast the story to the
original one and comparing the two
stories
well age of calamity may just have a
better story to tell
here are 11 reasons why that's true for
me and might be true for you
as well number 11. the champions every
beginning ending and sometimes even
midpoint in a mission features a
high quality fully voice acted cinematic
cutscene that serves to delve into each
of the champions in depths that were
never explored in the original game
now this is partially due to the fact
that the setup for age of calamity is
you know back in the day when all of the
champions were still
alive and breath of the wild is set in
the future after they've all been gone
for 100 years but
even so it feels like age of calamity
just gave them more development than
breath of the wild
even tried to here's an example of what
i mean if you tally up the entire
run time of all cutscenes in the game it
comes out to about 15 minutes shy of 2
hours however
as i am of the opinion that you should
never be blocked behind a paywall from
experiencing a game's
story because of this i'm only going to
count the original game's packaged
cutscenes and am not going to count the
paid dlc cutscenes towards breath of the
wild's total run time
age of calamity's cutscenes on the other
hand tally up to two and a half
hours now one might think at first
glance that there's really not that big
of a difference between the two
but keep in mind that breath of the
wild's run time includes all of the
present day cut scenes that take place
after all the champions were already
dead and
largely does not even include them so if
you only include the cutscenes featuring
the living champions of 100 years ago
showing their
living personalities and character
development that totals up to
about 31 minutes 31 minutes of character
development split between
four individuals versus age of
calamities two and a half
hours that heavily features the other
champions after beating both of these
games i definitely felt more connected
to each of the champions after watching
and hearing them for hours in age of
calamity
and yes even bird boy number 10 the
voice acting i don't know what happened
and maybe it's just the actor and me
talking but it felt like the actors were
super on the ball this time around
not trying to say they were bad
necessarily in the original game but
say what you will about the english
voices one thing we can all agree on is
the fact that not only did each of them
get
better with some of them reprising their
roles in completely different ways such
as impulse voice actress returning to
voice impa in a completely different
much more youthful fashion but there
were also some new additions that just
knocked our socks off
how the great calamity gunman
selected me this
cannot be my destiny it cannot be
9. the enemy speaking of new editions
one of the biggest changes to the story
of breath of the wild that age of
calamity introduced was the character
known as
astor pastor i mean astor for those who
don't know is a ganon worshiping prophet
who leads the yiga clan into combat
against the princess and her heroes and
is revealed to be the reason behind
their hostility at least in this version
of the story
the thing is i think the story needed
someone like him to pose as the villain
breath of the wild's main villain was
calamity gannon who was more of a
malicious being or
presence than an actual character it was
part of what made the game feel
somewhat emptier than the zelda games of
the past which have largely all featured
specific
villainous characters that link must
defeat namely one that you may have
heard of once or twice that goes by the
name of
ganondorf anyway astor provided age of
calamity story with an actual evil
presence that you can put a face to
every time you heard him laugh evilly or
insult coco or vow to destroy the
princess was another spark being lit in
your hero heart and his rather
disturbing presumed death at the end of
the game leaves you feeling like he
finally got what he deserved
unlike breath of the wild when defeating
ganon just kind of felt the same as
cleaning all the goop off that
godforsaken beach in mario sunshine
number 8 suga and the yiga clan
speaking of villains the entire yiga
clan in breath of the wild
always made very little sense to me
largely because their leader is such a
doofus
i mean he dances around stomping his
foot like a little baby and has a voice
like some sort of disney villain and is
so clumsy that he
actually defeats himself in the game why
and how exactly is this dreaded yiga
clan supposed to be intimidating or pose
any real threat at
all but age of calamity introduced a new
character that changed all of that
suga or as i like to call him big boy
this guy brought the clan the balance of
seriousness and
actual skill in contrast to koga's
otherwise
lack of those things suga was
intelligent powerful
driven and mysterious and served to
elevate the threat of the yiga clan in
the story and when he turns against
astor in the middle of the game it
creates
even more respect for him and his clan
by showing that they're not all just
bananas and fat jokes
they can actually change and evolve with
the story number 7
the music you guys music is a huge part
of a game's impact
no matter how you slice it in breath of
the wild the series veteran composer
koji kondo
actually stepped down from the role of
coming up with the game's music and was
replaced by a small team that included
manika katoaka
who previously composed the title screen
music for animal crossing new leaf now
there was never a
real concrete reason given for the
change of staffing but it can be assumed
that it was a decision made in favor of
breath of the wild's more
ambient focused soundtrack however
that's not to say there weren't any good
original tracks made for the game
each of the champions themes are amazing
and the theme for highway castle is
still on my playlist too this day but
even though breath of the wild had some
great music
the team for age of calamity used these
as stepping stones and not only wrote
some original new tracks but also
took all of these existing tracks from
breath of the wild and remade them
so expertly each of the champions themes
is the same tune but on steroids and
they use zelda's lullaby much more often
than the original game did whether
you're fighting
thousands of monsters or a main boss or
just watching the characters joke around
with each other
the music always seemed to fit
masterfully into the scene
number six time travel as you probably
know by now the entire game of age of
calamity takes place in an
alternate pass that was split when
terrico zelda's little eggbot
jumped back in time by a hundred years
in an effort to save everyone before the
calamity could kill
everyone if you think about it time
travel or manipulation is kind of a
staple in the zelda series oftentimes
making an appearance in many different
ways
for instance in ocarina of time
obviously there was time travel between
two different points in time creating
the major timeline split most fans are
very familiar with today
in majora's mask the entire game is
focused around going back in time
over and over again until you can save
the world
in wind waker hyrule castle is literally
paused in time until link can retrieve
the master sword
and skyward sword also heavily features
time travel to defeat demise with age of
calamity literally pulling the same kind
of time jump that's already been done in
skyward sword majora's mask and ocarina
of time and focusing on fixing the
events before they could get out of hand
it really did feel right at home in a
zelda narrative number five the story
shifting speaking of going back in time
when terrico first
front flipped into history and caused
some major changes to the past like the
activation of the shika towers
i and many others were pretty convinced
that nothing we were seeing at this
point was actually canon and to be
honest it's
either non-canon or takes place in a
different new timeline
which until expounded upon further makes
it only pseudo cannon since it doesn't
presently matter to the rest of the
timeline but that aside the changes that
the story writers made to the events of
100 years ago are
actually fantastic breath of the wild's
backstory is one of immense
tragedy and you feel it in the very
world around you
it's old weathered and forgotten but in
age of calamity
everybody feels alive and you get to
keep them that way when the first
sheikah tower is raised
eventually pura figures out how to
activate all of them which feels very
fitting for her character and gives her
more importance than she previously had
in breath of the wild the same goes for
robbie who with pura decoded tereko's
memories and was able to figure out
exactly when the calamity was going to
take place
well almost the champions getting to
meet each of their descendants and
followers was also
a very nice touch that i don't think
anybody saw coming i could go on but
i'll stop there
ultimately i feel like the shifts and
changes to breath of the wild's
backstory were
very welcome and deepened the connection
to the living world of hyrule
number 4 the masterful writing in the
same vein as the previous point
even though some things changed about
the story of 100 years ago
in pretty major ways they always
remained under the same spirit or
concept as the original story intended
for instance when zelda unlocks her
power originally as shown at the
beginning of this very game
it is in defense of link but after
everyone else has died in age of
calamity she unlocks her power in
defensive link
again but it's before everyone else died
the game is full of these parallels and
special moments that reference the
events of the original game while still
changing it up
very skillfully i was impressed number
three
the king i know i used the whole deeper
look into the lives of everyone who died
through cutscenes as a point earlier in
the video
but this one was way too important to
loop in with everybody else you see if
there's one truly hated character from
breath of the wild it's the king of
hyrule
due to his harsh conduct towards his
daughter zelda one would have to go
out of their way and read his
descriptions from the book of creating a
champion to ever know he
even truly loved her i see hatred
towards the king of hyrule
all the time and previously it was for
pretty good reason but in age of
calamity we actually get to see his
redemption
because not only is his life spared like
everyone else's but through this he
actually genuinely shows that he cares
very deeply for his daughter and even
apologizes to her for shirking his
responsibility as a father first and a
king second
even though it doesn't actually change
the horrible things he did to her when
she was growing up
such as being responsible for taking
tariko away in the first place
the fact that he is intent on giving his
life to save his precious daughter
and then they share this moment of
genuine tenderness towards one another
as a father and daughter should
just gave me chills because even though
he was mean to her and tried to force
her into discovering her powers in his
wife's absence
deep down she really was the most
important thing to him and all he was
trying to do was
save everyone since he knew the prophecy
stated that her powers needed to awaken
i mean look it even made master koga cry
number two the divine beasts even though
this isn't strictly a story element
it was a big enough and memorable enough
part of the gameplay which the story
depended on that i had to include it on
this list playing as each of the
incredibly powerful divine beasts makes
you wonder how ganon ever won
in the first place i mean yes it was by
taking control of them and not really
defeating them but that's besides the
point flying around as vam meadow
stomping around as varuta
ramming through enemies as vanoborus and
flinging lava everywhere as varudanya
were the elements of gameplay that
nobody knew they wanted but now can't
imagine the game without
it really makes you feel like they were
underused in the original game
especially with their dungeons each
being beatable in about 15 minutes or
less for a veteran zelda player and at
number one we have
link i'll just come right out and say it
i love what they did with link in this
game he has more emotion than what was
shown in breath of the wild and can
perform some pretty supernatural feats
and i'm not just talking about the
gameplay which probably shouldn't be
heralded as canon in the first place
in the original game we normally just
see the aftermath of what he's done but
don't ever really get to see him
in action except for when he's training
in the rain which is a cool scene don't
get me wrong
but it's not an actual fight in the
cutscenes for age of calamity though
he's shown
on screen to be essentially as fast or
faster than a guardian beam
can spar off against all four of the
blight cannons at once
can deflect this huge chunk of building
with one
arm and also leaps like 20 feet in the
air to finish climbing again with a jump
attack which i thought was an incredible
touch
he feels much more like the physical
boss that we know he is in breath of the
wild but never really got to see for
ourselves
and that pretty much sums up my list
what did you guys think is age of
calamity's story better than breath of
the wilds
just as good or worse let me know in the
comments below and also let me know what
your favorite part of the game was
thank you so much for watching it means
the world to me if you want to be my
favorite person ever please consider
dropping a like to get the video spread
around on youtube
and if you enjoy zelda games and would
like more nintendo content consider
subscribing to stick around for the next
one
huge thanks as always to my fabulous
supporters who make my day
every single day and i have some new
faces to introduce too
say hello to skyward gamer onyx plays
and just david who have all joined the
ranks of my elite
if you watching are interested in some
pretty awesome perks and helping the
next video come to life
feel free to check out that join button
below or follow the links in the
description to find out how also while
you're down there you'll find links to
my social media pages so come follow me
on instagram that's all i've got for
this one so as always i hope you have a
wonderful rest of your day
this is mason 10 abandoned signing out
[Music]
you